>>Paul Irish: Cool.
All right, guys.
My name is Paul Irish and I am a developer
advocate on the Chrome team.
I want to talk a little bit about tooling.
So this is about building Web apps, finding
the right software to make your process of
building Web apps fun, awesome, enjoyable,
less stressful, more productive, things like
that.
Now, I'm going to talk a little bit about
kind of how we're building Web apps today
and how I think we can build them in the future,
but for a second I want to take a few steps
back and walk back a few years, back to 2006
because this is the year that I wrote like
my first website where I was like doing all
the right things when it came to Web standards.
And I felt so good about the way that I was
doing it, so I was actually here and I did
something probably like this, and I was doing
a little bit of this and then this and then
that and then that and that, da, da...
This is typical, right?
[Laughter]
>>Paul Irish: Oh, there we go.
Nice!
Cool.
[ Applause ]
>>Paul Irish: All right.
I'm really glad we don't have to type that
out anymore.
That's really nice.
But this is like -- so what I actually did
is when I made this site, and it turned out
to be really nice, I did the whole thing in
Notepad.
And I think we consider it a little funny
now that I would write like pretty significant
site in Notepad, but at the time I was like,
"I'm a craftsman over my markup and I will
be one with it, and the closest I can be in
it is in Notepad exe."
So I just used that.
And it just seems kind of silly.
I thought I was so close to it, but really
it's not really craftsmanship.
That was handcraft.
That was like the Web's development equivalent
to whittling a stick.
And handcraft is more about choosing tools
well, finding the right tools to get the job
done and assist you.
And I noticed this too, I started at Google
about two years ago, and looking around when
you're surrounded by really smart people,
and you notice what the really productive
developers do.
And they know their -- they have tools that
they use, they know them really well, and
they embrace them.
And so I kind of like noticed that there was
a theme going on here.
And so I want to talk a little bit about tools.
And this is not about, you know, Google development
tools.
This is about -- you know, you don't have
to be building the next Gmail for this kind
stuff to apply to you.
It's for everyone.
A lot of people have been noticing this recently.
And I just want you to, like, think about
remember there was a point at which you didn't
actually use version control.
You might have been on a team and you're like,
Hey, I'm going to be editing, indexing HTML.
Can you hold on just a second?
Okay, you can do it now.
Like source safe.
It was, like, annoying, but version control
made it a lot better.
And we can focus on development, not tiresome
debugging when you don't want to be doing
it.
And then how much time have you lost when
you actually had a colon where you were supposed
to have a semi colon or an extra comma at
the end of your little object in JavaScript,
and you were like ah!
There's lots of funny things.
I'm not going to click to it.
It's a little not safe to work, commit logs
from last night, pulling in logs from GitHub
where people happen to use expletives because
they're a bit frustrated.
People that are making silly mistakes that
they probably don't need to.
So we're seeing a little bit of shift towards
looking at tools assisting us.
And Rebecca Murphy did a great post about
this sort of shift recently, and she said
we're seeing us focus from valuing trivia
to valuing tools.
And a similar thing was said a little bit
ago by Michael Lop, known by Rams online.
He's an engineering manager at Apple.
He said, There's a short list of tools that
you must be rabid about, rabid, foaming at
the mouth crazy.
And he went on to talk about how he used his
editor, his terminal and what made him productive.
And I think this is important to really identify
what you feel great about.
And so I've done a little bit of research
and it talks about this, and there's a lot
of tools.
When I say tools, it like covers a lot of
things.
So this is a quick way of trying to visualize
from start to end what are all the tools that
I use from the birth of a project to deploying
it out to the world.
And we're going to kind of walk through a
little bit of this, but focusing on your developer
workflow.
So I'll just -- we're going to walk through
the current workflow for Web app developers.
And really the way we'll start this off is
in your shell.
In your shell -- I'll bring mine up right
now.
Cool.
The first thing is I think you should make
it sexy.
Feel good about this terminal that you're
typing into.
There's a really great community on GitHub
around dot files, configuration files for
your bash prompt or your ZHS prompt, other
application configurations.
So I encourage you to go check that out, see
what other people are doing and customize
your shell and share your customizations with
other people.
There's a few favorites that I have.
One of them is a directory jumper called Z.
I'll show that now.
I can jump to any folder that I've been in
somewhat recently.
I'll jump over to the modernizer project.
You can type any portion of that word, hit
Z.
We jump right into that.
Now we'll actually go over to the HTML Please
project.
Just type in "Z please," and we jump over
into that folder, nice and easy.
Cool.
Now, moving on past my shell -- actually,
first, the server alias.
This is pretty cool.
This alias, this is just a bit of bash.
We are just firing up a simple Web server,
no big deal.
At the same time we're opening up browser
tab.
Configurable port if we want, but we'll default
to 8,000 if we want.
I'll do that now, type in server.
Cool.
And refresh.
Yeah, cool, awesome, good.
So we have my local HTML5 Please running right
here.
Now, coming back, the next part is the editor.
And the editor, you might have your own preferences.
That's fine, but the key to a good editor
is that it's an onion application, which is
to say that there's a nice learning curve
where you can kind of peel back the layers
of functionality and kind of grow from novice
to expert at a very easy pace.
So the other thing with an editor is that
more than any other tool, this is where your
investment in time and learning it well and
learning the features inside of it will pay
off huge dividends.
So I'll bring up mine right now.
Let's see.
I'm actually using Sublime text and we'll
bring this up and move it over here, and we're
going to bring up actually my script for this
file.
Nice.
Cool.
Now, one of the things that I've noticed developing
recently is that I've kind of, like, learned
new tricks, I like some of the features in
this editor.
And one of the things that I added to my editor
workflow recently was having linting.
And code linting built-in write live.
So I'll show you what I mean right now.
So here I have these three variable declarations.
It's cool.
I didn't actually write these three lines,
but maybe I'll refactor them a little bit.
Select them.
I will align -- that's nice.
Good thing.
I'll do a multiline select.
Move that over.
That's cool.
And then I'll go over and fix that.
And good.
Now, one of the things that it's helping me
out with here is I have this white box right
here and this is linter plug-in that's running
inside Sublime and it's telling me I have
a problem.
Now, way down at the bottom it says "H2 is
not defined."
And I'm like, but you're right here.
Hmm.
And what is the problem in this right here?
Yes, my semi colon should be a comma and I
should be stringing my variable declarations.
That's so nice.
Yes.
It's cool.
All right.
So yeah, I got lifing back and it was able
to, like, save me from an implied global variable,
which we don't want.
I probably would have caught that.
It would have been a syntax error when I refresh
the page, but I'm getting it caught right
here immediately.
So I like this.
In fact, I think code linting is your first
unit test.
Typically the first unit test that you might
write is the global there, does this thing
exist.
And even before that you get feedback on if
it's available.
And in JavaScript this is particularly important.
Some of the languages have rich static analysis
features.
JavaScript is a little hairy in that sort
of thing, but we have code linting.
I'm using JS right here, and I can get immediate
feedback on is my code syntactically sound
and is there anything that I should watch
out for, like what we just saw?
So one of the parts of this is I really like
getting the realtime feedback.
If you've seen the talk by Brett Victor, Invented
on Principle, one of the things that he talks
about is having immediate feedback between
your code and your results and getting that
feedback.
And so I'm going to show a little bit of kind
of what kind of tools provide this sort of
workflow these days.
So I'll move this back over here and I'll
open up the style folder or the style sheet
that we have.
I think it's style.scss.
So we're using Sass and Compass, and I'm going
to jump down to H1.
So what I'm going to do is just make an edit
in the text shadow and we'll just change this
part of the text shadow from this right here
up to 41 pixels and save it.
Now, nothing happens.
I refresh the page.
Okay, cool.
That's good.
But I can turn on this library load extension,
which is just available inside Chrome.
It communicates with the system application
back here.
And now any changes that I make are in fact
live.
So I make a change, I just hit save.
I don't have to go over and hit refresh.
That's good.
So I'll actually just say that that sounds
pretty good.
And I will go down here and add a little bit
more functionality.
Let's see, I'll do a CSS transition that I
want to see .4 seconds.
I'll apply that to all things.
And then add a hover state to it.
I think this time we'll do a transform.
Nice.
Okay.
So I just hit saved, I come over here with
my mouse and -- nice.
This is definitely an improvement and I will
be committing this to the repo right now.
[Laughter]
>>Paul Irish: Or not.
But that's cool.
But I'm getting my immediate feedback, so
I'm getting my Sass immediately recompiled
on the fly and then my CSS is being served
back to the browser.
Without even the browser refreshing I can
change the page, my scroll position is maintained
and just the style sheet is being swapped
in, which is really nice.
All right.
So I'm going to show a little bit of the browser
dev tools inside Chrome, some features that
help especially with building applications
that you may not be aware of.
The first is sourceURL.
And this is a feature that's been in the browser
for quite awhile.
This is a little demo set up by Ryan Sutton,
and so we have a little bit of Coffescript
right here in the middle.
I'm going to make a small little edit to this
Coffescript first.
Nice.
Cool.
I'll bring up the Chrome dev tools.
And -- that's pretty good.
Nice.
Now, normally I can take this Coffescript,
I can run it through Coffescript.js, compile
it into its JavaScript form, and if I run
it, it goes through eval.
And normally when you take text and run it
through eval, it evaluates, but it just kind
of disappears into thin air.
SourceURL is a way to basically treat that
as a file.
So if you see down at the bottom I'm adding
googleio.js and adding to compile.
Now you see it over here in the Chrome dev
tools.
And if you look over here we have what I just
added in the Coffescript, now compiled to
JavaScript, and at the side over here is the
sourceURL.
So this little line is indicating, hey, dev
tools.
I got this text, I threw it into eval, but
can you treat it as a file?
Thanks very much, that would be great.
So this is really nice, too.
So not only is it a file, but I get all the
features that I would expect.
So let's say break points.
First I'll just make sure that my cube function
is working all nicely.
Yes, good.
Cube files 125.
At a break point cube of five we break.
I can't actually check the value of X right
now.
We're looking good.
Yes, sure, we'll continue.
Or I can do a live edit.
I can immediately change this file on the
fly, we'll return 2 from square so now let
me ask for a cube and it should be 5 times
2.
Cool.
And we get our result, which is 10.
So I'm getting live edit and break points
on some JavaScript which was compiled down
from Coffescript all on the fly.
I'm showing up as real files.
That's pretty nice.
Ember actually uses sourceURL to great effect
to -- Ember the JavaScript library, to emulate
modules, which is really, really cool.
Another feature I want to show real quick
is source maps.
So if I bring back open my local HTML5 Please
and view the source, down at the bottom is
my original sources for the project.
Looks like we had some script tags pulling
in a few libraries and then this script.js
that I did before, but what really gets served
to the browser is script.min.js, which is
minified.
My Chrome extension is critifying this for
me, but I really want you to see that it's
minified.
Okay, cool.
Thank you, Chrome extension.
All right.
So the browser is actually receiving the minified
source, of course,
But down at the very bottom of it is a little
indication similar to what we saw with sourceURL,
only this time it's source mapping URL.
And this points over to a map file.
And this map file does -- basically takes
the identifiers in this compiled source and
maps it back to my original sources and says
these are the files.
And so what I can get are the results.
I open up my dev tools and instead of seeing
script.min.js I see my original sources all
in here.
And the cool thing is that the same thing
works over here.
Here's my nice edits that I made.
I can apply break points and click on any
-- and now we're actually broken in my original
source even though the browser is interpreting
the minified version.
So this is great for an environment like production
where you're serving up the compiled sources,
but you want to be able to debug the original
things you typed up.
All right.
Cool.
Lastly, if you noticed, this might look a
little different to you.
First of all, the dev tools are on the right-hand
side.
If you open up the settings panel which is
down here in the bottom right, we have a few
things in there.
So doc to right, which moves it over there.
Really like it in doc to right mode.
We have our step to bugging on the right-hand
side and I can get that out of the way.
My file's over here and I can get that out
of the way and view my scripts in their full
glory.
I can also jump to different scripts.
Instead of using this menu I can kind of hit
Command O and see all those scripts that are
available.
It's kind of get completion there.
Or Command Shift O and see all the functions
that are defined in this file, and now I'll
just bind -- yes, the sort function is what
I'm looking for.
I can jump immediately to that definition.
So a lot of nice things to make dealing with
a large JavaScript code base a bit easier
instead of the dev tools.
All right.
Now, I wonder about testing for a moment.
And this right here is actually a picture
from a series that we have up in the bathrooms
at the Googleplex in Mountain View, California.
The series is called Testing on the Toilet.
So each week there's a new sheet that gives
you some good tips for writing test against
your software.
Good reading material, too.
But it's important to write unit tests, so
I have a few ideas here.
First is that you should author your test
in whatever you feel most comfortable in,
so these days for JavaScript it would probably
be Jasmine Q unit or mocha.
They all have kind of different assertion
styles, and find whichever you like and you
feel comfortable writing those assertions
in.
Build up a large test suite and then it feels
so nice as a security blanket when you're
doing refactoring.
The other thing is you can execute these tests
that you've written in a variety of different
sessions, so like -- settings.
The first one is, of course, in the browser,
so this is the HTML5 test suite.
Run inside Q unit, inside the browser.
Pretty common.
You can also run the same tests inside a headless
browser, on demand, on the command line, so
I'll show that right now, I'll use grunt,
which is a node-based command line tool and
type grunt Q unit.
So this is actually going to fire up phantom.js,
which is a headless WebKit instance, toss
in those Q unit test suite and then check
that those indeed five assertions did pass.
So I'm able to run the exact same tests just
without leaving my command line here.
I can also run this -- run tests after I push
it up to version control, and let something
like continuous integration server test these
things, so we do this on the modernizer project.
So this is Travis.
Every time we put up a new commit on GitHub,
Travis comes in, pulls down the latest, and
actually does a similar thing, it takes our
Q unit test, throws it into phantom.js, and
then -- and then we're looking good.
It tells us if we're indeed passing or had
a little bit where I made some commits and
broke some things.
We fixed that.
It's good.
Another cool one.
This is really nice, again, from Ryan Setton.
He wrote a tool where we can take tests, not
only get results on the command line, but
be able to test browsers in the cloud, so
I'm going to take this same test suite that's
in Q unit, and toss it to bunyup, and bunyup
will then take that and call up a browser
static, which has a lot of browsers in the
cloud and also mobile emulators.
I'm not going to wait for this finish, but
it just called up some IOS emulators, and
it's gonna -- and it can check my test suite
against those and get the results back.
So this is really nice.
I can write my tests, be able to execute them,
in a number of different devices and browsers
on the fly without ever leaving right here.
All right.
When you have a build system, you wrote all
this stuff, you need to get it out to production.
A lot of things you need to do with a pretty
hefty Web app, and tackling all of these on
your own every time -- every time you make
changes is not going to work out so well,
so you're going to need some help.
I'm going to get into a little bit of this
later.
But after you deploy, one of the things that
I think that we often forget is keeping track
of your errors that clients have.
So this is a screen shot from errorception,
and it's showing my report from a Web app
that I somewhat hastily put up with some friends,
and telling me that I actually have -- people
are hitting some JavaScript errors in I9 and
Chrome, and, you know, I didn't hit any of
these errors, and none of the other developers
did, but -- but real users in the field are
hitting these, so I can get these reports
and make sure that I can fix all these for
everyone.
Okay.
So that was a lot of stuff, and sorry, but
-- so I was showing a lot of things, and it
was kind of like this is here, this is here,
and the feeling that I got was that this was
kind of like -- I mean, there's a lot of tools,
and they're all useful, but they kind of didn't
have this smooth integration, so me and some
people on my team thought about this and we
thought maybe there's something that we could
do to kind of make this work flow a bit more
smooth.
And so I'm going to talk to you today about
a project that we're going to show off called
Yeoman.
So the ideas behind Yeoman is that we think
you should be able to go from your idea to
a rough prototype in ten minutes.
I say "rough", but I mean like a prototype
that you're actually going to continue developing,
like you're using all the tools inside that
prototype that you would normally use in a
Web app, and you're going to keep going from
that.
We also want to make sure that we can reduce
friction from the things that you should be
doing, such as testing.
And now, you probably heard that you should
not repeat yourself when you're coding; same
thing applies to your tools.
You shouldn't have to type -- you shouldn't
have to run build.sh every single time you
change a file.
So these things should be automatic.
So what Yeoman is is it's an open source set
of tools, frameworks, libraries, that accelerate
building good Web apps.
So has some things in it, so authoring abstractions,
linting, testing, build tools, these things
that I've been talking about, but we've been
focusing on providing nice, smooth developer
ergonomics so it feels good to use.
So there's a few things inside of it.
Things -- these names you should be familiar
with: Compass, sass, CoffeeScript, module
support, by the way of AMD, and ecmascript
6.
We'll get to that in a minute.
Twitter bootstrap, stripped HTML5 boilerplate,
some testing things, Jasmine, phantom jas,
image compression.
All right.
So I'm going to do a demo and I'm actually
going to skip the first step, the first step
is a little shell script that gets your developer
environment all set and going, gets you installed
with node and NPM and home brew.
Get a few of the dependencies out of the way.
You're going to want, because, you know, sometimes
I'll end up switching to a new machine, and
getting your own developer environment going
takes awhile.
So we wanted to make sure that you could get
rid of that -- an old set in a few minutes.
All right.
So I'm going to go to temp.
Nice.
All right.
We're going to kick off a new project.
So a lot of what we have in Yeoman is accessible
on the command line, and so I can just type
Yeoman command, and we have a few things available
in here.
We have init, build, server, test, and some
other stuff we're going to get to later.
So what we're going to do here is we're going
to start a new project.
I'll name this project IO app.
And inside our app, we're going to type Yeoman
in it.
Cool.
So we're starting off a new project.
Things are good.
It's going to ask us a few questions.
What's the name of the project.
Description.
It's going to pull a little bit of the get
metadata from my get config, so some of these
defaults probably will make sense for me.
And that's good.
Now, it's going to take all of this and create
a nice little package .json file which I might
want.
Now there's a few things it's going to ask
me if I want.
Do I want Twitter bootstrap?
Yeah.
Required JS?
I'll pull that in for now.
And experimental support for ecmascript 6
modules, let's do it.
All right.
I say yes, we get a bunch of files written
and we're good.
Just to show kind of what this created, I'm
going to take a tree and pipe it through to
Les, so let's see, we've got a good deal of
bootstrap here, and then bootstrap -- a little
bit of HTML5 boilerplate going on here, some
more bootstrap, Jasmine going on down here.
Cool.
Now -- now, the next thing I'm just going
to open this up inside my text editor, and
so we have here a little stripped version
of HTML5 boilerplate and I'll add in some
text, and I'm actually just going to use a
little bit of zen coding to save some time.
Nice.
Hello I/O. Yeoman in action.
Now, we have a server built into Yeoman.
And the cool thing here is that we're actually
taking -- because when you run a server, you
actually want to be able to watch your changes
too.
So you set up a server.
It immediately actually opens up that result
inside the browser as well, and you're off.
So now I'm going to open up my style sheet.
All right.
And we have in here, we're going to pull in
Twitter bootstrap, and I'll bring that in
here, and now watch as I hit save on this
file.
Hit save.
I'll watch task.
Notice that it immediately changes.
And then we run it through compass, we hit
the reload task and you saw that it changes
up here.
So I'm now able to add whatever I want inside
my text editor, and get immediate results
down at the bottom, or in my browser.
So do a little bit of styles here.
Save.
That looks pretty good.
A little bit of color over here.
Save.
Nice.
Cool.
So I'm able to just go run all this immediately
through Coffee Script -- sorry, through compass,
compile it down to my resulting CSS and then
get the results immediately showing over here.
The cool thing is that we're actually not
even using any sort of Chrome extension to
get the lab reload functionality inside -- inside
the view in my browser.
Now, this is cool, and I wanted to bring up
testing, because I mentioned that before.
We can just go over to slash test, and we
have our Jasmine test suite, all green, looking
good, we see in the browser, looks good.
Like I said before, I think it's really nice
to have this available at the command line
two, so we'll type in Yeoman test.
We're going to take that jasmine suite and
throw it into phantom.js and get our same
passing results.
Cool.
I should mention here that we're using grunt
again to use a lot of this system level functionality.
It's a great project for this sort of thing,
and we're leaning heavily on it.
All right.
Cool.
Now, let's move over to another project.
I want to bring up this application, and we'll
kick it off right now.
Bring this up.
Nice.
All right.
So this should look pretty familiar to you.
This is your standard to-do app.
Common -- a large portion of this came from
the to do MBC project where you can see a
basic to do app built in a number of different
frameworks and libraries.
So let's see, go to I/O, do a talk.
Nice.
Cool.
So we've got this basic functionality, and
that's good.
I want to show a little bit of how this was
built.
So right inside here, we view source, and
we're pulling in required.js and the main
module that we're pulling in is main.
And so I'm actually going to take a quick
detour and talk about modules.
All right.
So modules, the quick elevator pitch on modules
is that the key to building a large Web app
is to not construct a large Web app; it is
to break it up into small libraries and small
parts.
Writing code into small files feels good,
and we can do that when we use modules.
With structured modules we can also define
what our dependencies are, and when we do
this, we're actually able to just define our
dependencies a single time, so let's say we're
not using modules, so you would probably have
your HTML file, you would have bunch of script
tags in the order that they need to be in,
and then you have your build system which
is going to, you know, concatenate all your
files, and you have to specify your order
and your dependencies over there as well.
Modules we can only -- we can just define
that structure just in one place.
Another advantage is that as you develop,
you might stop using code, and in modules,
code you stop using just gets stripped out
when it goes out to builds.
So there's a few different ways to write modules,
and I'm going to show two of them here.
The first is AMD modules, so these are asynchronous
modules.
They have dependency resolution, help you
to not write global variables, and it has
a very rich plug-in ecosystem that I'm going
to show as well as smart-build optimization.
So this is an example of, let's say, a to
do controller, and we're going to pull in
this file, and bring it in to our app as a
to do view, and then our to do controller
is going to return an object that includes
some stuff and then a render method.
All right.
Cool.
Now, on to the next module.
This is ES 6 modules, ecmascript 6 also ecmascript
harmony.
Now, this is actually coming from ecmascript
committee, TC39, who thought that, you know,
people were kind of doing this in the JavaScript
world; let's find a way to make this actually
happen in the language itself, so offering
a native solution.
Has a flexible syntax, beyond what we have
just down here, so what we have is we're pulling
in a module called "to do view", from this
file, and importing it into this file, we
have some functionality, and then we can export
whatever we want, so in this case we're going
to export a function called render where we
do some stuff.
Actually point out I am saying ES 6.
There is a little bit of conversation happening
like right now about if this is going to make
it into ecmascript version 6 or the next version
after that, so we'll see how that goes.
But we wanted to experiment with this, and
see if Yeoman could give us an ability to
try out this style.
So back to -- back to the code.
I said that this was using required.js, so
I'm going to open up the -- our source of
this app, and I'll open up main.js.
So this is the module it's pulling in, and
looks like we're initializing an app right
after we pull in the task app module, and
we have a little coffee script pre-filter
on this, so looks like -- all right, cool.
So this is indeed AMD, but it is of course
CoffeeScript.
You can see at the top we're playing in a
few other modules into this file, and then
we have our application set up where we're
defining our structure of our to dos.
Now, one of these modules that we're pulling
this is this fun module, nice.
And we're pulling it in with an HM pre-filter,
stands for harmony.
So I'm going to go over to that real quick.
Fun.
All right.
So this here is an ecmascript harmony module.
We are pulling a few things into it.
So we're pulling in speech, from -- from this
guy over here, and this is actually the E
speak speech synthesizer client, and the cool
thing about this speech synthesizer is that
it's actually written in C++, but it was run
through emscripten which is a research project
by Mozilla that can port C++ into JavaScript,
and so now we're taking that and we're exposing
it through ecmascript harmony modules and
bringing that out, so we pull in this module,
and we also got this guy going on here, and
down here we're going to use this speech module
at the bottom, and pull out this speak method.
Cool.
Coming back into our app.
I can see down here when we create a new item,
I'm going to uncomment out this guy, and comment
out this guy.
Nice.
Come back here, and refresh the page.
Good.
And now let's try this out.
>>> Remember to ace the demo.
>>Paul Irish: Yeah.
Nice, cool.
So nailed it.
Awesome.
All right.
So the cool thing here is that we have a C++
library that was ported into JavaScript via
emscripten, exposed via ecmascript 6 module
into our CoffeeScript application compiled
down into ecmascript 5 JavaScript, and now
we've got a (indiscernible), so I think we're
in a good place.
Cool.
All right.
One of the things that we wanted to do with
Yeoman is find out how we can iterate on it
in a way that kind of was based on how people
are using it.
So we have a thing in there that can report
exactly anonymous metrics around what are
the commands that are typed in, so any kind
of Yeoman commands, and this way we can get
a better idea on how people are using it,
so they can make good changes and really make
sure that the tool fits its users.
Another thing that it can do is answer questions
like what's the popularity difference between
backbone and ember, or what's the adoption
rate of ES 6 modules?
So I think this is really cool.
And we also want to make sure that all this
-- all this data is accessible to anyone that
wants to see it.
I want to take a moment just to talk about
package management.
So I don't know about you guys, but if I have
to update like a library that I depend on
somewhere, the first thing that happens is
someone probably tells me, hey, that Jay creates
1.5 up to 1.8 alpha.
You should probably update.
Okay, okay.
I'll go to the site, I'll find the download
button, and I'll download that to my downloads,
then I'll move that into the app folder, and
then I'll like fix the script tag because
it's a new version file and fix that, and
that's -- that's not great, so why do we need
package management for clientside JavaScript?
Because what I just described is not fun.
And then more like an Ecosystem level, common
code gets duplicated across a good size app,
you probably have code to bind a function
to a scope like four times.
Another thing that happens is that libraries
get fragmented.
This is why we have things like the jQuery
empire and then the YUI and dojo and closure
areas where things are not really interoperable,
and we have fragmented communities and libraries.
So with package management, we can have something
like a longer dependency chain.
A good example of this is the Chaplin project
which helps building applications in backbone.
Chaplin depends on backbone and some other
libraries which depend on jQuery and underscore.
That comes really easy.
Better package management, we can define that
dependency tree which informs a build system
to be really smart about building that out
for a very optimized output for production.
Then as a library author, it's really nice
for your users to both consume your library
as a regular old install and also as a dependency
of something else.
How about instead of all of those steps, we
just have something Yeoman installed backbone,
we have to update it instead of all of these
steps, Yeoman, very casually, hey, man, JavaScript
library update, you have got to update your
backbone, it's the new thing.
You're like, cool, cool, I got it, Yeoman,
update backbone.
So I'm going to show you a quick look at Bower.
Bower is a package manager, it's being built
by Jacob Thorton, who is one of the devs behind
Twitter bootstrap and Alex MacCaw behind The
Spine (indiscernible).
And what we did is we basically took Bower
and wrapped it right inside of Yeoman so that
again this accesses through the same interface.
So we're over here in the I/O app and we'll
do Yeoman install backbone.
So right now, what it's doing, is Yeoman is
talking to Bower, Bower is going to go and
talk to the registry, say, Hey, I need backbone,
cool.
I just got the backbone package, it's dependent
-- my dependencies are underscore and jQuery,
please get those, okay, cool, got those.
And now we've installed into our app into
the js browser modules backbone jQuery and
underscore.
So if I go into js browser modules, we have
all of our files right there.
So I'm saving a lot of time not going and
getting all of these things and keeping them
up to date.
I'm able to manage my dependencies from my
app right here on the command line, which
is really nice.
So this is -- this is where things are going
with that.
So -- so in summary for Yeoman, we can start
out new projects really easily.
We get a fast, iterative loop when we are
doing development.
Understanding preprocessors like Sass and
CoffeeScript, module systems like AMD and
ES6.
I didn't show how we can run our files against
js hint.
Or even the build script, which is pretty
robust.
It's built actually on the original build
script for the HTML5 boilerplate.
But we have done a lot of research into image
optimization and found the most effective
loss list image compression we can do.
So Yeoman is available on the dev val for
preview, if you go to Yeoman.io you can sign
up and get notified when it's totally ready.
We're just doing a little bit of buckling
to make sure that we're looking good.
We also want to make sure that our package
manager has enough packages so that when you
want to start an app and add things, everything
is there for you as you want it.
So we're letting in a few people, just to
kind of kick the tires and we'll have it out
available for everyone publicly soon.
All right.
So ... summary.
Tools are your friends, they're good, they
increase your productivity, lower your stress,
help you out when you use them in a work flow
that works really well for you.
We're working on Yeoman.
Tell -- make it easier to consume these smart
tooling choices and help you build compelling
web apps.
And thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>>Paul Irish: If you have any questions, go
ahead and step up to the mics in the aisles
and that would be rad.
>>> Thanks, Paul.
>>Paul Irish: You're welcome.
>>> So Paul.
>>Paul Irish: Sir?
>>> I saw Jasmine, is there going to be other
testing like plug-ins or --
>>Paul Irish: So since we are built on -- on
Grunt, if you are familiar with that, swapping
it out for -- for a different testing suite
is as easy as editing the Grunt file.
So it's not too bad.
But we -- we made choices that -- we wanted
to have some smart defaults in there, so we
went with Jasmine because we really like its
style.
So it is configurable, but we wanted to have
something that gets you off and going from
the start.
>>> Awesome.
>>Paul Irish: Cool.
>>> Can I get an invite?
[Laughter]
>>Paul Irish: Yeah, yeah.
You talk to me, talk to me.
>>> Um, when you -- after you installed Yeoman
and you were making changes, changes were
loading in the browser, was that live reload
or was that something in Yeoman?
>>Paul Irish: So we are actually leveraging
the JavaScript shim that the live reload project
used and we're injecting that into the page.
And so we're using a portion of the live reload,
but it's really just JavaScript that's making
that happen.
>>> Okay.
So ensure one doesn't have to have live reload
to have that feature.
>>Paul Irish: Right.
That feature comes through Yeoman, so you
don't even have to have anything else installed
yet.
>>> Okay, thanks.
>>> So you showed us the testing and the development
side.
I'm guessing part of the build process that
you didn't have time to show us was building
for deployment.
Would that also include being able to use
the closure compiler to have source mapping?
Um ... yeah.
Right now, um -- right now our build step
goes through uglify, but we're looking at
a nice way to run it through a closure compiler,
because I like source maps just as much as
you do.
So there's -- there's a few issues and discussions
open to get source mapping into Uglify and
to CoffeeScript, neither of them have landed
yet.
So we're waiting for that, but in the meantime,
yeah, I would really love to find a nice way
to get source maps into the closure compiler.
>>> Right.
And there was an issue around having multiple
source maps and trying to read from each other.
I'll catch you at the code lab.
>>Paul Irish: Sure, yeah, sounds good.
Sir?
>>> All right.
What kind of requirements do I need -- for
my server when I want to deploy this Yeoman
created app?
>>Paul Irish: Um, no specific requirement.
It's completely up to you.
So -- so it's -- it's basically we don't make
any requirements as far as your back end.
It stays completely client side only whereas
another solution might say this is your database
on the backend or we're going to serve it
up to Engine X or something like that, but
that is completely up to you.
>>> I see.
Okay.
>>Paul Irish: Yes, sir, one more.
>>> This one is for Louie.
So how much do you know about like the Bower
package manager, how hard is it going to be
to get a package into it?
I noticed that it looked like it was cloning,
so if you push that back up to GitHub, like,
is there like weird issues?
>>Paul Irish: Um ... well, I can answer the
first part at least.
So it was previously called nest and I'm accessing
it, this way.
And registering a new package is as easy as
that.
Bower.
Register the name and the URL of the get repo.
It's very, very easy and there's a package.json
file that has the meta data available for
the package.
There's no strict dependency on GitHub, but
there is a strict dependency on git, and clone
each package, find out its dependencies and
the team is finding ways to optimize that
and say, for instance, grab the zip download
if it's a GitHub situation instead of cloning
the entire repo, finding out how to make that
really nice.
Cool?
All right.
Thank you guys, appreciate it.
[ Applause ]